uh herschel walker our friend herschel
walker was asked about the economy and
his answer was completely unintelligent
uh and unintelligible as well
now i want to uh kind of remind you guys
of the context here herschel walker is
the republican senate candidate from
georgia
he's running against incumbent
democratic senator rafael warnock
recently walker weighed in on such
issues as 911
um foreign policy as well as education
and none of his opinions made any sense
and yet
he is now leading
against raphael warnock most recently
walker appeared on the newsmax show
spicer and company yes with sean spicer
trump's
short-lived sort of short-lived press
secretary when he was president and his
answer
doesn't make any sense about the economy
take a listen to this helping spend more
and democrats spend more voting on some
of those bills how are you talking about
this spending and is it a winning issue
in georgia
well it's a winning issue this economy
is a winning issue because i i think
anyone with any types of sense and i i
hate to say that people on the left
don't have sense but you know you don't
spend what you don't have right and that
seemed to be what the left has gotten
good at continuing to spend the people's
money and uh this will be good stewards
with people money they seem to have to
do that and also crime you know behind
has really gone up crime has really
gotten terrible and
you know i'm running against a man that
had called our officers all men and
women in blue thugs and helping so his
view on the economy is
don't spend what you don't have
and crime as well now this guy is
winning this race and that's completely
outrageous but i want to i spotted a
very interesting comment on our
subreddit from user mr waidaban okay
mr waidaban
sort of tried to explain why walker is
doing well in his race
and what mr waidaban said is herschel
walker is expressing
the human mental state after consuming
thousands of hours of right wing media
and when we hear these word salads from
herschel walker according to this reddit
user it resonates with this frenzied
mental state of the target audience the
people that are just furious they don't
even know why but they're furious and
they're scared and they're angry
because they've been watching fox news
and newsmax
which is designed to agitate it's
designed to make people agitated and
angry by pressing these buttons and all
you need to do to press the buttons is
to say these things and then if you want
to interpret it that way when herschel
walker goes money we don't have and
crime
it's a crazy thing it's just it's all
over the place it's frenetic
but it's just pushing those buttons of
the very people that it's designed to
and i think that that's a very it's it's
an astute comment quite frankly um
herschel walker also talking about how
he's not doing this for money he's not
running for money who does that remind
you of them when i get to washington i'm
not going to go to washington like
senator why not has done and tried to
double my income you know i've been
blessed through the lord jesus to make
money so i'm not going to washington and
make money yeah sounds a lot like what
donald trump was saying in 2016. i don't
need this i don't i could just hang out
and be fine i'm i don't need the money i
won't even take my salary and we know
how that worked out raping and pillaging
all sorts of institutions and resources
of the united states so when i hear i
don't really need the money from doing
this
to me it only raises red flags because
it's so trumpian if you're listening
today and you want to see these clips in
their full glory we'll have them on our
instagram that's at davidpakmanshow on
instagram